if you recognize this book and you
bought it chances are you never finished
it this is thinking fast and slow and
like me it is one of the most abandoned
books of all time this basically means
according to the Hawking index that it
scores amazingly as far as buying it
starting it and stopping it goes people
just can't seem to be able to get
through this book no matter how popular
recommended or incredible it is and
unfortunately this is not at all
uncommon almost everyone has a last book
that they never finished from last month
last year or back when they were in high
school feeling that you know maybe books
aren't for them and then as adults we
get recommended these really dance but
incredible bugs and added on to our
already crazy personal and work lives we
just feel that because we're not
enjoying or distracted from this reading
we're maybe just not the kind of person
who is into those sort of things as
someone who has read and enjoyed
thousands of books in my life I am fully
convinced that it is some small but
significant changes that make all the
difference in being able to enjoy and
continue a reading habit and so today I
wanted to share with you a life's worth
of intuition and experience when it
comes to approaching and conceptualizing
books and reading so that hopefully by
the end of this video you might pick up
something that might change the way that
you approach books maybe help you
understand why you couldn't finish
thinking fast and slow and maybe also
how you could be able to do that if you
wanted to I am going to talk today about
how to train your eyes and how to train
your focus to enjoy reading so let's get
straight into it the first thing I'm
going to be talking about is the ability
to train our eyes to distinguish between
different types of books and I'm not
talking here about book categories like
is it fiction or non-fiction or Memoir
or history but I'm talking about the
categories based on the way that the
content is delivered and how that
affects my energy I find that if there
is a mismatch between my energy energy
levels or what I currently need to be
entertained and the wavelengths or what
the book requires in order to be read
that's just a bad time and I'm going to
stop reading and hate what I'm doing so
in my life I use three categories of
reading based on how they deliver the
content and how they affect my energy in
the first of these categories is
informative books and thinking fast and
slow is definitely there as is Stephen
Hawking's The Grand Design the purpose
of informative books is to get me
educated on a specific topic or bits of
information and the way that they
deliver their content is in very very
clear chunks and these chunks tend to be
in chapters so every chapter makes a
clear point and it's kind of
distinguished and delineated very often
at the end of these chapters I feel like
I am done so I describe these books as
being more swappers or Stoppers a
swapper in the sense that sometimes I
read Stephen Hawking's The Grand Design
and I might get halfway through it and
think actually I'm much more interested
in black holes than everything else that
he's talking talking about so I'll swap
it for another book because it's
information for information or a stopper
in the sense that I might just get too
tired by focusing on something dense for
a long time and I just want to stop
reading these books are not bingeable in
the second category I put expressive
books and these are books that share the
thoughts and opinions of the writer this
is a book that I'm reading at the moment
Beauty basically books like this tend to
be essays or philosophy where it's just
an opinion piece but more importantly
the way that this information is
delivered is in tiny little chunks
usually every concept is centered around
a paragraph or sometimes if you're
reading pure philosophy I find that the
concept is delivered even in single
sentences where I'll read a sentence and
I'll have enough to think about it these
are Stoppers they take away my energy
it's very difficult to get through these
books in one sitting I don't think
they're even made for that but if I
don't keep this in mind it's really
difficult to read Because I'll start
them and then I'll just want to stop and
think these are to be contrasted with my
third category which are store books and
these are books that deliver the whole
content in one group a great example are
fictional books of course but it doesn't
need to be just romance or crime or
fiction or thriller it can also be well
written Memoirs and I'm going to use
some examples of things later too in a
storybook there is a clear line the way
the content is delivered is in one big
chunk you either read the whole book or
nothing at all almost but it keeps you
interested and entertained from start to
finish it kind of pulls you along it so
I can already see in these three
categories there's a very different
method when I will approach a book what
I will do is look first at of course the
title and the synopsis so the summary
that tells me what the book is about and
then later I'll just have a flick
through the book itself here are what
I'm trying to see is the language of the
book How complicated or easy it is
because this will definitely affect my
binge ability of a book A book with very
easy language that I'm very interested
in or familiar with will be something
that I'll want to definitely binge no
matter what the content is like and and
on the other end for example even though
Shakespeare is technically fiction the
fact that it is written in language that
I'm very unfamiliar with makes the
chunks a lot smaller rather than having
this bingeable quality to it and lastly
to determine the language what I would
do is I would look at the beginning of
each chapter of the first sentences and
see how they start the more story like
they seem the more context defining they
seem then the more likely that this is
going to be a book that's going to have
a story element to it or an engaging
element to it rather than being this
pure almost school science book or essay
the value of being able to quickly
categorize books like this means that I
know how to approach them and how to
read them when I pick up something
bingeable which is informative I know I
can get through this book fairly quickly
and that's absolutely fine and even when
I pick up a short book which is
philosophy and is quite expressive and
information dense I know that this might
sometimes take me weeks or months to get
through so knowing how much energy and
attention this will need will kind of
set me up for my next step which is
training my focus to read and I find
that this is the biggest issue the thing
that people mentioned the most to me is
that they often get distracted for
reading and the reason that they don't
read as much as they want is because
their focus just goes away and I find
this absolutely hilarious because being
the most unfocused person ever I feel
like it has more to do with how you are
matching the book Vibe with your focus
at the moment rather than being
generally a focused or an unfocused
person so let me just explain if you
come back from a long day of work and
you're tired and exhausted and you know
you have a million other things to do
tomorrow and you want to unwind with
thinking fast and slow that's not going
to be a guaranteed success and actually
it's probably not going to be an
activity that you can keep up for long
but that doesn't mean that you hate the
book or that you can't read the book it
just means that there is an energy and a
focus mismatch in order to discuss Focus
I'm going to use Barbara Oakley's two
main modes of functioning which are
diffuse mode and focus mode I would
Define diffuse mode the mode that we are
mostly in when we are considering to
read this is kind of the state where you
can have a TV show in the background
know you're just like scrolling through
a feed on some social media app and
you're kind of thinking of the messages
you need to respond to this is the
diffuse mode you can focus on a lot of
different things but nothing
specifically you're kind of like
mellowing and doing nothing and this is
when the thought might come into your
head that maybe I should read right now
as opposed to focus mode which is
something that requires a hundred
percent attention on the thing that you
are doing now the issue with diffuse
mode is that because our attention
requirement is really really low we can
very easily think that oh I should read
right now that might be a thing that I
want to do but if we pick up a book
which is very very dense like thinking
fast and slow or Stephen Hawking's books
the attention requirement in order to
enjoy this book and understand this book
is so much higher that this mismatch
means that we're very very quickly just
going to lose our Focus the little bit
of focus that is on it is not engaged
enough we're not enjoying the book so
we're just like I'm just going to pull
out my phone so I think this is where
the mismatch comes from the most and
what I would recommend in this case is
that if you are in diffuse mode where
you're like my brain does not want to do
a lot of work right now I cannot commit
to working 100 on something which is
very dense I just want to chill and you
still want to read I would recommend
picking up a book which has a really
really strong storyline something that
has a low energy or attention
requirement but that keeps you very very
engaged in this way either your
attention ramps up as you're reading it
or you can actually enjoy it with a low
attention that you need so this might be
like a novel or a fictional story or I
keep imagining Markham guard wall but
some sort of non-fictional or
educational writing that is really
informal and written in a very very
engaging style this might be a good
match for that time in order to keep
your attention on the thing that you are
doing the times of the day that I
personally read in diffuse mode are
usually before I go to sleep because
this is where I am either completely
exhausted and happy or I am most likely
completely exhausted and stressed and
overthink thinking so my focus is either
on the fact that I want to sleep or what
I'm happy about or the majority of my
focus is kind of on the things that I'm
stressing about that I want to be
distracted from so I'm definitely in a
diffuse mode where I don't have a lot of
attention or energy because it's really
late to give to books and in this case I
always read something fictional
something really really light easy
language something to just help me like
grab some part of my attention enough
for me to just Drift Off to Sleep When I
get tired and these are the sorts of
reading I would recommend in those
instances on the other hand we have
Focus mode and focus mode is where we
wish we all were all of the time this is
where you're paying 100 attention to the
thing that you are doing and it's really
great to be reading in Focus mode
because you're actually if you're in it
you're actually enjoying what you're
doing and you're getting a lot of
benefits from the book that you are
reading or the tasks that you are doing
but the thing is we only have so much
Focus or energy to give things in a day
there's this huge barrier tantry and
this huge friction to start where when
you see the requirement of this book and
you go oh do I want to do this right now
if you say yes and you actually want to
do it that's great you're going to love
the book if not you're probably going to
like drop it and leave it my
recommendations for books which require
Focus mode are one to either increase
the amount of attention that you can
give it in the moment and I'll explain
how I try to do this or to take it with
you when you have no other option but to
read so in the first instance what
you're doing is if you're trying to read
thinking fast and slow it's much better
to actually answer the questions of why
did you stop reading it last time why
did you actually want to read this what
results can you get from this why is
this a good use of your time right now
and kind of doing these analytical
questions will actually help you a lot
more to increase your motivation to do
this task in the moment rather than
trying to like unreasonably almost force
yourself to do it which might not work
or if your answer is no but you want it
to be yes you can match this with trying
to negotiate with yourself what you feel
either way on the other hand these are
the books that I would put in your bag
so if you're stuck on the Underground
and your headphones died or are your
train stop somewhere and you're stuck
for 30 minutes or you it's really to put
up on your headphones somewhere or you
hate your music and you don't have
internet access I would pick up this
book then so when you are somewhere that
you have no other options airports
things like that where you have no other
option but to read this is a good space
to have this book as an option because
this is a time where you're kind of
frustrated you have a lot of focus to
give something because you usually have
a lot of energy but you have nothing to
focus on at the time and this can then
become your default these are also great
books to Tire you so for example the
book Beauty I always keep in my bed so
when I have a day where I am wide awake
for some reason when I'm supposed to be
sleeping and I have a lot of energy I
will pick this book up because it has a
huge friction to start I know that my
function at that time is to enjoy myself
and also Tire myself enough to get a
sleep and also because the chunks are so
small I can stop at any paragraph or any
sentence and I'm absolutely fine I can
start reading later versus a story where
it's really difficult to do this and
also my last bit of advice is to create
artificial special Cliffhangers so for
example a lot of non-fiction writers or
educational writers don't really stop
the book at an interesting place they
kind of resolve every chapter because
they're obviously optimized for giving
information rather than being
interesting but it's therefore sometimes
our task to make the book interesting so
maybe stop the chapter before the last
three pages of it or stop resolving your
needs to understand something and leave
it for another time so you have an extra
reason to pick up the book where you
left off with these Concepts it's
hopefully easier to understand where you
stand when it is or isn't a good time to
read what the vibe of the book is in
general and not beat yourself up if
you're curious about the thoughts that I
read specifically and my thoughts and
opinions on them which can be really
brutal and honest sometimes I kind of
grazed over these topics almost and
didn't go into the depth that I would
have wanted in order to make it stand
out for me necessarily I have a whole
series of videos where I go into detail
and just sit down casually and talk you
through a summary my main learning
points what I love and what I hate and
what I change in my life from the things
that I gather in the books that I read
this series of videos is over on nebula
a platform where me and a bunch of other
educational creatures have come together
to put a lot of other videos that don't
really fit the algorithms and the
platform on YouTube this is a space for
us to experiment with different types of
content and videos I find it a great
space to talk more about reading which I
absolutely love but I also take video
recommendations is there if there's
anything you would like me to put there
I already have a few of these book
summary videos up on nebula if you would
like to have a look at them immediately
but I will also be adding more as I go
forward with the books that I read on
nebula there's no ads there's no
algorithm so you're not distracted by
other things you just go to watch the
thing that you want and you can leave
and also a lot of educational creators
are actually on the platform so you
might find they're able to watch a lot
of our main YouTube videos ad free over
there so it's actually overall an
incredible package I will have a link in
my description which will give you a
monthly or a yearly discount to access
nebula but I do want to thank them so
much for sponsoring this video and
making the platform and those book
summary videos possible because I
actually find that side so much fun and
lastly I do want to mention that as
someone with challenges of my own I do
dye and cringe inside a little when I do
mention numbers or being able to do
things like read as much fully well
knowing how underdiagnosed lots of
reading and learning disabilities are so
if you are struggling with these things
I do apologize this video is not at all
potentially helpful for you and um yeah
I just wanted to say sorry about that
but otherwise if you made it so far
thank you so much for spending this time
with me I hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day be kind to yourself and
others and don't believe everything you
think thanks bye